so don't ask me how but another trailer
got leaked The Dark Knight Rises trailer
than The Avengers trailer which I am not
watching I refuse I will watch it with
Captain America now the trailer for the
amazing spider-man has somehow gotten
leaked now I know a lot of you are gonna
ask where's the trailer where can i see
it where's the link there's no point in
me putting a link in the description
because it'll be removed in a second if
you really want to see the trailer
search the amazing spider-man and search
by upload date I'm not very happy about
the idea of a reboot I want to stress to
you though that I have a lot of respect
for the people involved with the movie
the director and the actors and I feel
like they have in all ways the ability
to make a good movie I just have never
been a fan of it from the very beginning
and I don't like the suit as a lot of
people know so I was really eager to see
what it really had to offer because I
think that you know you no matter what
you may think of a movie once you
finally see a trailer it's like oh okay
and kind of see where they're going my
emotions are very mixed because it
obviously looks like they're making a
competent film in a film that is going
to be you know looks nice and is made
well it seems like they're doing a
really good job with that and that's not
necessarily a big display of talent when
you have millions and millions of
dollars at your disposal
just looks way too dark spider-man's
very light spider-man's happy so I'm not
supposed to be a very relatable hero
because he's a kid in school and because
of that you care about him and he has
everyday problems in this trailer I'm
not getting that the end of the trailer
has this big first person point of view
shot that's supposed to be very you know
that's awesome and stuff and it felt
like a video game to me when I saw it it
really felt like a video game a buddy of
mine theory the film fan said hey have
you ever heard of the game Mirror's Edge
showed me a trailer for it it seems like
a pretty much exact copy of that I mean
there was even a part of it where I
thought it was literally a copy of that
game and that the trailer was fake but
it just looks so similar I like Emma
Stone a lot I think she's really pretty
I don't really feel Andrew Garfield is
Peter Parker he seems way too much of a
jock to be a Peter Parker and he has
that that look hey yeah you know I don't
want to be a jerk and I don't want
everyone to be mad at me because they're
excited for spider-man but I just feel
like this movie isn't gonna be good I
just feel like with this movie that it's
just not going the direction spider-man
should go in when an origin story is
already told is close to the comic book
possible I mean some of the shots in the
first spider-man film are frame for
frame what was in the original comics it
was so faithful to the comics there's no
point in going back through another
origin story again it just seems so
stupid it seems really really useless I
mean imagine after the Dark Knight Rises
comes out if another director says let's
do Batman again which they're talking
about and let's do the origin story
again it's gonna be like I'm pretty sure
Batman Begins pretty much aced it we'll
see we'll see I might be completely
wrong but I'm just not thinking this
movie's gonna be that good I hope it is
so don't get me wrong I have a lot of
respect to the people involved but after
seeing this trailer I'm not feeling it
so stay tuned tomorrow because I'm
seeing Captain America and I'll have a
little thing about the Avengers trailer
- after actually see it in theatres so
look forward to that
[Music]